la bande de gaza territoires
palestiniens dont nous parlons presque
chaque jour malheureusement est il faut
le savoir une bande de terrain
désertique d'environ 45 km à peine de
long sur 8 km de large un peu plus grand
que l'île de ré et sur ce territoire
vista un million quatre cent mille
habitants alors entre le blocus
israélien la mauvaise organisation et la
corruption de l'autorité palestinienne
il ne faut pas s'étonner qu'une majorité
d'enfants en bas âge souffrent de
malnutrition
charles enderlin reportage sans l'aide
de l' agence de l'onu pour les réfugiés
il n'y aurait rien à manger dans la
minuscule cuisine de sa mère elle a 22
ans trois enfants son mari policier
palestinien ne gagne que l'équivalent de
160 euros par mois sanaa souffrent de
malnutrition
elle perd ses cheveux y suit un
traitement les nations unies fournissent
à la famille riz sucre farine huile lait
en poudre
cela ne suffit pas toujours pour le
moins alors quand je n'ai plus rien je
n'emprunte pas mais parfois c'est trop
dur à l'âge de mon aise de ma famille
ce cas est loin d'être isolé dans les
territoires palestiniens où la situation
économique est catastrophique avec plus
de la moitié de chômeurs et des salaires
souvent craybas 17% des enfants de moins
de cinq ans souffrent de malnutrition
chronique 13% de malnutrition grave ou
modéré
camp de réfugiés de la bande de gaza
sont les pupilles les cas d'insuffisance
en vitamines et en protéines sont
diagnostiqués lors de visites de routine
dans les cliniques des nations unies
la problème le problème s'aggrave et ce
en dépit des efforts de notre agence
pour distribuer de la nourriture à plus
de 120 mille familles dans la bande de
gaza les responsables de l'aide aux
réfugiés ont lancé sans grand succès un
appel à la communauté internationale
pour qu'elle finance une aide
alimentaire d'urgence aux palestiniens